every day there's a new front line in
the fight against kovat 19 his outbreak
is seemingly unrelenting and many
countries that had appeared to slow down
the transmission of coronavirus are now
facing the prospect of a second wave of
infections in soif and her a Chinese
town bordering Russia medics are
preparing for cases to increase sharply
and are taking precautions when the door
is closed it becomes a confined space
and this machine will extract air this
is called negative pressure Chinese
cities near the border with Russia are
tightening restrictions strict border
controls are now a reality for almost
every corner of the world experts say
the only chance of life returning to
normal is a vaccine and authorities in
Beijing say they've now approved
clinical testing for three vaccines and
are working swiftly to make them a
reality or McCampbell even by you me all
day and far we will make if it's to do a
good job in developing these vaccines so
they can be used as quickly as possible
like China in the US the first human
trial of a vaccine has also skipped
animal testing but experts say that
could be risky when you got so many
people working on so many different
vaccines everyone's gonna be competing
say there's going to be the best and if
you rush a vaccine too much and you get
side effects and that's going to have a
really deleterious effect while trials
are happening at a rapid pace the World
Health Organization says the vaccine is
at least 12 to 18 months away Jessica
Washington al-jazeera